maisto caffè adesso va da
benvenuti solita storia oggi dovevamo
scappare da un nuovo anno e ti chiamo
amore di lo potete vedere qua non so
cosa sia sembra una sorta di spavento ha
posto il pupazzo animatronics dovremmo
scappare dalla sua casa infatti questo
gioco si chiama schepp freddy's mansions
chiese sempre titoli mi dimentico se
prima
mettetevi comodi prete tv una copertina
è lasciata un beniamino
del gioco cosa ci aspetta ovviamente
questo è un escape rombo paurosa penso
che somigli un po alla scorsa e skype
room che abbiamo fatto di anit ron però
nome si possono per ora la fidanzata di
balbi che faceva super paura perché
c'era un sacco di jobs che progettava
queste non l'avete vista siamo a
conciliare l'entrata della casa di
freddy andiamo avete preso la coperta
che vi ho detto prima perché è coperta e
perché freddi quindi siccome
tra l'altro noi siamo finalmente fuori
che un gay bar che anche al sud è
arrivato il freddo freddo allora dice
stai attento e ci sono due frecce ha
preso ma tu dove sei ne sono stato preso
da freddy mezzo per sé che vai avanti
senza aspettarmi
corrida che lascia dobbiamo mandare qua
per fare mi sa che dobbiamo leggere le
indicazioni and more
veramente allora andiamo a sinistra
proviamo tutte star stories vega dei
correntisti bossi si è proprio con
melanie laurent si sente anche come
quell'altro escape room
l'altra escape lungo vi ricordate quella
della prigione questo è successo mi
signore dio siren mi avete scritto
quella sorta di poliziotto inquietante
sembra anche un po quello
perché il germe a 36 senso che si sta
profilando
sono questi spuntoni vivete nei commenti
quante volte si separassero vitale in
questo skyroom ogni tanto 60 la risata
di freddy quindi vuol dire che si sta
guardando no
sta guardando solo disprezzo veramente
di vitale per quello ride
beh dovete ripeto ho ricominciato
nessuno prima che arrivi davanti
oppure dare dei premi allora freccia
sinistra se l'ato non quello meno ridere
no
adesso devo essere concentrato attento
qua il pavimento della pa pensi magari
essere ancora qui a soul dai bambini
siamo tipo nei sotterranei pesavo basti
tu invece uno era una ragazza faccia
come senza faccia avanti
attento a non cadere nella ix come
chiedere non brevissima io non credo che
mi faceva caramella lido dove sono un
sacco di carmellino perché non avevo
voglio la caramella dobbiamo prenderne
10 e si è preso due finora pure io ho
sempre fatto è che spunti fuori
all'improvviso e c'era anche altre patch
di cemento aumenta
chiaro qua vai piano prima velocissimo
sotterranei fissate andremo anche i
piani di sopra della casa
trovo il modo di aprire il cancello
dobbiamo trovare forse c'è qualcosa qua
ma una caramella forse qua sopra
dobbiamo trovare una chiave allora che
cos'è questo rumore brava ok
una leva
sciopero giusto forse ora troveremo
freddi là dentro vicino mamma mia
vediamo
che
ha visto inseguendo vicente meglio non
meno di non ridere io cosa dovete
lodando io sul passato
ma mai vista no non l'ho vista
l'italia non si accorge di niente
la caramella
giorno verranno velocissimo perché io
devo arrivare prima di
questo vero e ora dove siamo siamo
saliti al piano di sopra
ci sono dei dubbi
vediamo quante volte cadrà abitare
[Musica]
hanno devi dire solo dice quel caso per
davvero passato non mi piace per portare
fortuna avvitare lasciate un mi piace
anzi non lasciate come piace per vedere
ancora più su faccenda menti tipizzare
però mi piace perché mi piace ma io
quando ha preso la caramella ciao ma
adesso che ho preso la caramella come
devo fare a saltare lì qua ci sono dei
lander nice prime fino a prima delle
caramelle come sempre
ce l'ha fatta
mi sembrava strano che non fosse ancora
amore ap sfracellato avveniva davanti ai
sono in vantaggio adesso c'è un buco
però vediamo chi arriva prima alla fine
di queste schede
vita l'espresso il latte o fioritto
alcuni dei vetri sono deboli
allora non era quello
quindi che cosa dobbiamo trovare la
strada giusta
la caramella
le caramelle era una trappola
allora vi problema ora quindi la grande
amica qual è il vetro giusto non era
quello della caramella ok fare questo io
se con vitale
rimorso si quale storia di questi due
animali dimentico ed aromi con il primo
buon era ovvio che so devo andare di qua
poi dando la quale questo allora
ricordiamo si destra a sinistra fu bravo
ok quindi dritto su caratteri aspetta
che se non mi ricordo che nella la
strada come farò a ricordarmeli tutti
poi questo caffè adesso fa
poi dico no per completare dobbiamo
dobbiamo ricordarcelo i vetri altrimenti
morira 200 mila volte più poi erano due
avanti mi sembra insieme no no aspetta
io ho saltato avanti prima con
l'altro
continua a mettere davvero e ci sarà un
trucco forse c'è il trucco per scoprire
[Applauso]
questo trucco se l'avete tra l'altro
detto voi e cioè di passare attraverso
esse passa attraverso e quello sbagliato
se non passa attraverso e quello giu
salmaso prodotto di notte dobbiamo
trovare un qualcosa che ci faccia capire
se è quello giusto non prendi che ha
fatto cose steve room ha pensato a tutto
allora vada questa parte io non me li
ricorda tutti rimarcano ancora non sa
che non ci sta un paio allora io provo
ad andare avanti non è quello anzi
beh almeno ora te lo ricordi
speriamo
no aspetta un momento posti alcuni li
abbiamo già rotti non dovremmo vederli
genere infatti sembra delle scritture
rombo più difficili guarda se guardi
dall'alto più di quelli che abbiamo già
rotto
no ma fissa è
[Risate]
distratto non so cosa devo saltare
ne ho fatti due avanti o non mi ricordo
quale adesso e vedi qua non ci mette
dentro infatti si sa non c'è abbiamo
indovinati senza romperli a
bonera adesso ecco questo non fare ora
no dimmi quel vero quello dopo chi si
ricorda
no possiamo andare sul filo no
è una delle partite che pronti e
difficile che abbiamo mai fatto segreto
ok potrò fidarmi di vitale ecco quello
che abbiamo rotto quindi per forza
questo che adesso
questo bravo e ora aspetta che non mi
ricordo ecco ce n'è solo uno c'è stato
con la destra perché l'ultras interrotto
almeno lo fa li fa vedere entrambi bene
ma che rotola st bravo a capire quale
sarà o no dai ne manca solo uno qualità
con la
frase prenderti sacrificato per me
come lo ha rivolto un piano da poco o è
stata super difficile questa parte
abbiamo qualche parte che che ci sta
guardando
quindi queste sono dei laser t
qualcuno si è forzato io no
ma anche io ecco
[Musica]
ci sono dei libri malefici
sembrano quelli di ritmo bisogna stare
attenti secondo me visto che si mangiano
le queste che ti ma per fortuna non si
muovono
affettano dai questo napoli
adesso però dobbiamo stare fermi libri
book bella questa ripresa
sono caduto
che sta facendo questi suoni strani è un
suono tipo di elettricità quindi ho
paura e ci sia delle giocatrici dei
lander e poi
c'è un suono di un pannello
per cui chi è del sangue immagino dei
laser e non saprei dove andare adesso
sopra vediamo no che strano forse qua ok
sul tubo è accaduto aspetta dormivo in
chiesto non capisco forse abbiamo
sbagliato qualcosa o no forse ho capito
dobbiamo salire qua sulle lampade
dove lei qui soprano canelli
errore dove siamo cos'è questo quindi
questa è una libreria e questa notte c'è
un fantasma si è visto che ho scritto
spegne il fuoco come lo spagnolo
ora dobbiamo trovare qualcosa perfetta
bravo
no decisamente non bisogna buttarsi
allora dobbiamo trovare il motore cosa
ne pensa la scala questa crisi
sono più di uno i fantasmi
ok sono qui sul attento non farti
prendere dei fantasmì partiti prendono
attenta
ma stasera quella avuto una netta
per poco
[Musica]
penso di sì meglio di no
dai vieni pure una punta ma si riduce
suppongo
mai premuto la rete no
sindone come sarebbero capiti anche
sentiamo i due gioco anche noi deve
premere pulsanti allenerebbe ok allora
vola povero l'europa che vitale sta
arrivando per cui c'è scritto c'è
scritto freddi star in modo ho detto che
sta arrivando
non lo so dobbiamo buttarsi qua penso e
beffati a scappare velocissimo
la via d'uscita velocità
[Musica]
non ci credo ma come lo si deve essere
presa incredibile spetta qui adesso sono
sicuro che c'è una trappola si sa che
bello gli spuntoni chi si volesse assi
care ok passato e aspetta no tu non sai
cosa fare ma
sotto ci crede di vivere poi perché no
aspetta
gli ultimi due poi passare
tranquillamente ma vai vai papa condanna
[Applauso]
farcela posso farcela via via v navi
rapina
cos'era non lo so ok ce l'ho fatta
scritto che dobbiamo notare ok
non
so perché ma nelle mura per me ma adoro
quando si deve mutare cara mamma
ma anche se un pò difficile si sta
aprendo la caramella a a un po difficile
muoversi quando si vota pure super
divertente di questa età deve se ne sono
e ci va fuori
mi manca solo una caramella animi già
note
dove siamo
occorre che questa possiamo far
scivolare
sono schiacciate riusciti a uscire non
ci credo a o senza dover affrontare
freddi di nuovo siamo sulla parte
ma è dove ci ha portato
io
stavo che avremmo dovuto riaffrontare
prendi un sacco di volte meno
però non abbiamo trovato l'ultima
caramello purtroppo presa
bene
e ora vi lasciamo con quattro case dire
tu puoi cliccare per vedere industrie
altri video cliccate su quella che
preferite buona visione
[Musica]